as great cower competition in Africa
heats up Germany's Chancellor says it's
time for her own country's firms to take
a new look at the continents economic
opportunities to that end she invited
heads of state from 12 African countries
to Berlin this week her initiative
compact with Africa foresees a mutually
beneficial deal if African governments
promote reformed Germany will promote
investment but will the private sector
play along two firms have enough trust
to take the leap economic upswing in
Africa who really profits that's our
topic
[Music]
and here to debate the risks and
opportunities of Germany's Africa
strategy is Vania Tata
she is a computer scientist with roots
in Cameroon and serves as the
editor-in-chief of the magazine Africa
positive
she says the compact with Africa
primarily serves the interest of Western
investors it's also a pleasure to
welcome Eman Seif Eldin she's a human
rights activist from Sudan who's been
living in Germany since 2016
she says the investment and trade
provisions should be based on
partnership and not on superiority and
I'm very pleased to welcome my colleague
from dwz Africa desk Daniel pouts who
has reported from numerous African
countries over the past 12 years he says
unless African governments and
international partners do their part the
poor will be left out with dire
consequences so let me start with you
via Tata and ask you about the first
part of our title namely economic
upswing
we often hear there's a lot more good
news coming out of Africa than the
Western media typically report now with
a magazine entitled Africa positive I
guess you're trying to change that can
something like this initiative the
compact with Africa and this conference
that was held this week can they shift
the narrative on Africa I think for the
meantime yeah in Germany yeah but I
think after a few weeks people are going
to forget about it because I think then
the narratives about Africa has to be
constantly repeated in the society so
that we can change the way the German
companies see Africa development because
normally now in the German narrative
Africa is mostly associated with it you
know with donations you know and not
with them and not with economic
development and I think that's a
narrative that is very important because
that's what is going to show the
companies here or the investors here
that there is a lot in this continent
you know like instead of only
concentrating on the Rome
two years and on the oil I mean we have
a lot of potentials we have a lot of
young talented entrepreneurs but they
need capital they need investment
capital both from the our government and
good from investors of foreign direct
investors but I think the compact with
Africa doesn't really address these
issues yes in fact I said in your
opening statement it serves the
interests of Western investors but
doesn't Western investment generate jobs
doesn't it create a climate that leads
to growth but not with this initiative
in the way I see it because if you look
at it critically
it focuses on large-scale investment you
know but most of the companies all most
of the little small and medium-sized
companies in African countries are
mostly informal you know and they really
need a lot of capital maybe not very
large but then it may be small capital
in order for them to like grow you know
and those are the companies that are
going to create jobs because they are
local companies I mean when you look at
Compaq with Africa it focuses on the big
guys you know and they're going to come
with their pension funds you know to
invest so that they can make much more
things much more profit you know but we
need investment that is going to go at
the bottom of the pyramid that is going
to create more jobs in the societies
similar to what Daniel Pearl said in his
opening statement he said that we need
to make sure that growth and investment
benefit the poor you've been reporting
as I said from Africa for some years now
what are the main obstacles that in fact
hinder that from happening well I think
one issue is what guidelines are in
place to really make sure that the local
people benefit I remember visiting a
project in rural Sierra Leone where a
Western company came and I think even
backed with with funds from Western
development organizations to set up a
plantation to produce palm oil locally
but the problem is they were only hiring
locals as unskilled workers and they
were given a job for maybe one month for
maybe three months and then that was it
they were out of the job they were not
earning salaries that we were really
helping them to turn their lives around
they're kids to school or maybe to
invest for example by building a house
and then you know paying a local company
so that you see that money is actually
going and stimulating economic growth so
for me it's really an issue about what
guidelines do we have in science so the
compact and the conference talked a lot
about reform would you say that they do
take some steps to addressing those
problems
I am very doubtful there it always
sounds as if many people believe it's
only a matter of bringing more private
investment to Africa and then it will be
a self-starter I do not really see that
people take this into account
you said investment and trade base must
be based on mutual respect
so the compact and also the conference
that was just hosted they are explicitly
for seeing reform partnerships would you
say that meets your demand I guess no
because the compact with Africa
strategies and policies that very much
depend on the depth and lawns that in
that will end up in empowering the
African people because we are always
taking the international the i/os the
international organizations recipes that
we have to lift this the the subsistence
or the the the help on the basic needs
of the of the poor people like in health
sector or education sector then after
years you find the country is having a
lot of burden of these depths on
shoulder and we are still on the same
circle of government of poverty that's
why I think compact with Africa is not
meeting the demands of Africans rather
more it the the compact with Africa it's
an investment strategy and economical
development that needs to provide
chances for young people to work
more jobs but when we look deep these
investments are not targeting education
and absolutely not vocational training
that is very much needed for for a for
work market and when we don't have
skilled workers or we cannot meet the
demand of these markets then we need
then the investors we rely on somebody
from outside and that is why it opened
chances for Western people not for the
African people and if I take Sudan as an
example although Sudan is not part of
the compact with Africa but there is
lots of policies and strategies that
been made specifically to Sudan as in
Marshall and hearten process and
different other and roc process lots of
processes coming from European Union
stores Sudan but the beneficiaries are
not the Africans or the nation the
Sudanese people instead these policies
have been very much drawn on very much
negative impact in our country let's
delve a little bit deeper on what the
compact foresees in terms of reform
partnerships one partnership with
Senegal was being showcased at this
week's conference let's hear what
leaders from both sides had to say
whether it's about peace climate
protection economic development
migration or other big issues of our
times we all agree that with over 50
countries and a growing population
especially a young population Africa is
playing an important role in solving
global problems
the compact actually will help the
government in all the stakeholders to
implement reforms that will improve our
ranking for the ease of doing business
of now so after Africa the growth
continent of the future we're building
our partnership on an equal footing a
win-win situation for both sides if
you're by do let me go to you via Tata
we heard the Senegalese Minister they're
talking about
the reform partnership would you agree
that a partnership like this one can in
fact promote effective reform are there
concrete steps that you would say they
are helpful while there are some
concrete steps in this initiative
compact with Africa but I think that's
not really the problems that are really
affecting the economic development of
many African countries that I involve in
this compact with Africa we should look
at the foundation of the stagnation of
economic development in African
countries and you see when you look at
it critically it's also because of the
colonial connections thus most of these
countries have with European countries
and also if you look at like for example
you see France the role Frank's place in
many African countries you know with the
monetary decisions that have been taken
in these countries everything is being
controlled by Frank so it means a lot of
African countries are not independent
and if a country is not independent it
cannot carry out its development
decisions on its own because somebody is
always involving him he's ourself inside
so I think Africans Africans themselves
they have to look for a way to break
away from this change that are
preventing the African countries from
developing and the most important thing
for me is to see how we can use our
resources that we have back home to add
value to products before we export them
out of the continent that would be the
only way that we are going to create a
lot of employment for the youth because
if we don't produce what what we consume
as Africans we are going to have the
same problems and these initiatives are
not going to solve it how much interest
to African leaders themselves or at
least many African leaders themselves
really have in reform are there many who
themselves profit literally profit from
perpetuating the status quo of course
not only the Africans that are profiting
from perpetuating of the this African
nation or elongation of these sufferings
of the African nations it's the Western
countries are also the same thing they
favored to have such kind of weak and
corrupt leaders in in the top of the
hierarchy of African continent that is
because of so many things that the
money-launderer issues and so many
economical big economical issues that
going on arms market that is also
flourishing in Africa the and I think
coming back to to her point that it we
really need to look in a critical way to
compact with Africa if the partners the
European partners really really apply
the compact with Africa if we are
looking not only to France France is
really controlling and having in a
moment to the world and UK also UK also
is having I talked to us a little bit
more about African leadership itself in
let's not only talk about pressure from
outside but let's talk about what is
generated on corruption from inside okay
I give you an example of Sudan because I
am come across that I know we were
struggling against Bashir regime that
corrupt regime that committed the crimes
against humanity and genocide and the
country for so long time whenever the
regime is weak whenever there is no any
economical flows of money or banking or
anything we got money comes from Europe
in such a kind kind of projects like
simple hearten project that is in 2017
we had a very good apprise people were
demonstration and in the roads to to
toast the Vichy regime but it's a
hearten process has started and millions
of dollars millions of euros have been
invested in this government so that to
stabilize the system that really corrupt
and that really sustained the sufferings
of Africans and plus a project that have
been initiated to hinder the influx of
migrants to Europe that Khartoum process
within this context lots huge money have
been getting its way to to corrupt
militias and government so even if the
nation's the Africans have the will to
break down this vicious circle of of of
Safa but we have external factors that
affect our our will and our our
ambitions of having good governance in
the country Daniel I posed that question
in a rather generalized way saying most
African leaders but in fact there are
wide discrepancies aren't there now the
compact includes a couple of countries
that are often seen as beacons Ethiopia
and Rwanda on the other hand it also
includes Egypt which surely is not noted
for its interest in breaking the status
quo how do you figure that
does that make sense for you well I
think even the two beacons Rhonda and
Ethiopia are often criticized especially
for the human rights record Ethiopia is
also grappling with internal conflicts
but also the government has come under
fire so I think these countries were
chosen according to economic interests
but good governance apparently was not
the primary factor to determine which
countries could be part of the compact
with Africa initiative and I think there
is a great mistake I think you also need
to promote good countries would you want
to include then we isn't this sort of it
seems to me all of you are to some
degree arguing it's all or nothing don't
we need to move step by step and aren't
there countries where you do see some
potential for cooperation on trade and
investment possibly beginning to change
the dynamics I don't really see that the
political dynamics in these countries
are changing I think it actually helps
the leaders to remain in power if they
have good relations with the West if
development aid is flowing or if you
even have cooperation in the security
sector for instance as it was the case
with with Sudan as you mentioned
I think there is even a certain danger
although I understand the Western
interests to cooperate with these
governments but I think it is also a
dangerous situation because you might
help governments to remain in power
despite a very bad human rights record
so taking this to an extreme are you
suggesting African countries would be
better off if the flows stopped I think
that's the opinion that they always
propagate because I think if African
countries can concentrate on the
internal struggles that they have
because we have a lot of internal
struggles and most of these are very
complex you know because they also come
from these structures that we inherited
from the colonial time so I think the
first thing is we have to sit together
within our countries and maybe with with
the neighboring countries and look for
ways and solutions of tackling these
internal struggles and if we do then you
then you are going to see that the
inter-african trade is going to increase
because we Africans we have to trade
with each other we don't have to focus
our mind on Europe you know and those
are the things that I think if we start
step-by-step solving the right problems
then we will be sitting here and talking
about initiatives that are coming from
Europe from from Russia from China you
know to come and save Africa no we have
to save ourselves still I think in the
issue of investment if we any investment
will not favor to have any money in a
country that is an politically unstable
and this instability this situation is
very much related to the policies of
European Union that's right so I think
either those people are throwing money
on nothing because I don't I don't
believe in sustainability of long term
these projects will not be sustained for
long term conditions or years rather
more there will be destruction its
destruction somehow to these projects by
the instability investing in war
investing in militias investing in
sustaining the in democratic
systems in our countries so all this
kind of things that will not generate or
will not make failure the most investors
to let me let me bring in another short
report that we have and see whether I
can provoke you a little bit because it
purports to tell a positive story
Germany launched the compact in 2017
during its presidency of the g20 group
of industrialized and developing
countries for an investment in the
partner countries to the compact has
risen since then albeit modestly most of
the increase though has gone to just
four countries Egypt Morocco Ethiopia
and Ghana let's take a closer look at
one story Accra over 2.3 million people
live in Ghana's capital with more coming
in every day even now the city is short
around two million apartments
construction is going ahead full
capacity the potential was great enough
for German drywall maker Knopf to open a
branch in Ghana but even the best
materials are useless if nobody knows
how to handle them and our target is to
equip local personnel in the building
and construction industry to gain
employment basically to earn a
livelihood with assistance from the
German Gates said Development Agency the
company set up a training center 350
young people have already completed
training here architects civil engineers
and tradesmen thousands more are
expected to follow
can this set an example for other
African countries so let me put that
question straight away to Daniel but
with this preface to the question we
heard the Chancellor in the report
before talking about migration it is
pretty easy to conclude that a lot of
this is all about migration many African
countries have huge youth populations
not enough jobs to go around there is a
lot of pressure on young people to go
somewhere else
when the opportunities are better can a
project like that one that we just saw
make a difference yes I think and I
think the compact also has a potential
because I mean every country every
continent also needs needs economic ties
with the rest of the world I mean nobody
can survive alone so I think also the
compact has potential because
infrastructure projects for instance the
idea to improve energy supply also helps
to stimulate local growth and that in
turn can create jobs for the young
people that are there that I entire need
of jobs and also macro economic reforms
like countries that are part of the
compact have to keep inflation at bay
they have to make sure that there but
the budget deficits remain within
certain limits that of course can also
help local business so I think yeah
there is also some potential in the in
the compact as well
they let me ask you this because we're
seeing a lot of interest in Africa in
other areas of the world Russia held its
own summit on Africa just a few weeks
ago China is deeply engaged in many
African countries India expanding its
own trade and investment with Africa do
these countries by attaching fewer
strings to their support offer more
partnership and do more for young people
and the poor than for instance Germany
well let's be realistic each of this
country has its own interest no control
be going to Africa just because they are
going there for friendship
it's all interest yes those doing the
same thing that the European countries
are doing but I mean we should look at
the form what are the African countries
doing they should be the people to set
the pace they should be the people to
set the right
measures that are going to profit their
own population so up till now I think
the problem has been most of our
governments don't set the right measures
that profit the majority of the
population and why is it that she said
before that most of these governments we
are they are supported by by by foreign
powers and foreign multinationals and we
have to deal with that because if we
don't deal with that we can we'll
continue to see this cycle repeating and
repeating and for me I think the African
youth at the moment they are saying we
want to profit from the resources of the
continent we want to have perspective in
our continent we don't really need to go
out that our government have to be
responsible in the first place to us and
not to foreign investors then we need
investors B doesn't mean we have to take
all type of investors that are coming
Africa it meant seven German development
NGOs and some international ones as well
say that Germans support and and
international support should be linked
to very clear human rights and
environmental standards would you
yourself also working with an NGO agree
with that and would you say it's still
feasible given the presence of nations
like China and Russia that attach fewer
conditions to their support I actually
one of the major critics on the compact
with Africa is that the lack of
environmental issues in the programs
which is now climate change is a very
very serious issue in Horn of Africa and
in North sub-saharan Africa where a very
serious drought that hits the lack of
child and where the the European Union
is very much interested I think without
tackling these issues nothing is going
to be we are still living in one
continent and we are affecting each
other and a one planet also climate
issues is its fairest human rights is
rather more on top of the agenda because
most of the most of the low loans and
subsidies that the African governments
gets it goes corrupted Lee
in or invested in in a way or another in
abuse of human beings like what is
happening in combating migration issues
that is a very serious issue for me that
what I have seen in in the cooperation
between between in Germany and libyan
both gods where the the refugees have
been kept in in detentions in the very
serious conditions and inhuman aspect
very quick answer Daniel pelts if you
would I want to come back to our title
economic upswing in Africa who really
benefits what's your answer well I think
at the moment much more needs to be done
to make sure that the poor really
benefit at the moment it's not a
self-starter to make sure that the poor
are really gonna benefit thank you thank
you to all of you for being with us
today and thanks to all of you out there
for tuning in see you soon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]